okay so how does bitcoin solve this okay
solve this problem
and before actually before you do that
how do you explain to people
like dummies out there like me what
bitcoin is
somebody has no clue how do you explain
it right
so bitcoin is
a new sort of evolution in uh
like monetary technology and
i guess the sort of like elevator pitch
is is it's
it's an uncensorable uh
unconfiscatable uh
fixed supply monetary
easily transferable transmittable
monetary
unit okay so it
there's a lot of like if you exist in
the world we live in today
like there's capital controls that keep
you from moving your capital from
place to place there there's tons of
middlemen
tons of middlemen yes it also cuts out
the middleman
in the early days of bitcoin we had like
an easy pitch and that was hey check it
out i can send you money
between our phones because bitcoin kind
of
had that was sort of revolutionary in
like 2009
but now everybody does that with like
cash app and stuff so that's right
that's cool but what makes bitcoin
different and bitcoin and cryptocurrency
is different is that
um the
well let me talk about what happens when
the government
or banks or whatever and you know
basically issue the
do the fraction reserve scheme issue all
the money what we see
is so like this money is just injected
into the economy
like it didn't come from tax revenues it
came from that sort of mechanism i was
telling you about where the federal
reserve buys the debt
and just creates the money but the
economy is still the economy it's still
the same
as it was the day before they sent these
checks out
they're still the same amount of stuff
yeah still the same amount of houses
they're still the same amount of food
still the same you know the economy
hasn't grown uh overnight
to you know to match whatever percentage
increase
the supply of money was so what you end
up having is you have these
you have more and more dollars chasing
after the same amount of goods and
services
and so what you see happening like for
instance real estate is you say okay
my client really likes this house let's
make an offer
i call the listing agent oh well sorry
we already have
10 offers on this house so if you want
if you want it um you know you got to
pay more
you need to go over list price so okay
we'll
go over list price and we'll go over and
then we'll hey we'll put an escalation
clause in which basically says we'll go
a thousand dollars more than the highest
bidder you know
wow stuff like that yeah to try and get
the house and so
what happens is the price gets bid up
right and uh
and part of that is because there's more
of these dollars in the system and also
you know interest rates are low
um which is another kind of
aspect of inflation um
so all these dollars are chasing after
the same amount assets we have is
price inflation which means the prices
of everything goes up
and so when you magnify this effect over
you know the federal reserve's been
around for 107 years since 1913.
when you when you magnify that out over
100 years
of this sort of gradual debasement of
the money
the dollar is worth a fraction of one
percent of what it was when the federal
reserve was started
so you have to ask yourself where did
that money go um
like where did that purchasing power go
like who got it
and the answer is it goes to the people
who
who get the money first
so if it's called the cantillian effect
if you want to google it
but can it can't somebody say it
cantalon
cantillion cantillion effect okay
basically the the first person that gets
that new money
they can go out and spend it in the
world at the same prices as things were
yesterday
before the market has had a chance to
realize that hey there's all this new
money in the world
um so you know where are we gonna
uh so they get to purchase it at sort of
a lower price
than everybody else so they say a month
later if the money supplies increased by
10
what that will mean is in a month or so
once the market's kind of worked this
out
everything will cost 10 more
so the guy that bought the item for 10
percent less
with that money when he first got it has
essentially
you know since since the money was just
made out of thin air for him
he he he stole 10 percent of the
purchasing power of everybody in the
economy
by injecting that new currency
right so with bitcoin
one of the key uh
sort of founding principles of bitcoin
is it has a fixed supply
so it it's it's it's emitted gradually
over time
through a process called mining um
but at some point it tapers off to zero
that are emitted and and the total
amount that will ever exist is 21
million
bitcoins but how how is it possible how
can you cut it off so at one point
miners won't be able to make any money
on it well the miners also make money on
transaction fees so when people
want to make a transaction they
um they pay what's called a minor fee in
bitcoin
and the fee it's just like a market so
if the bitcoins network's kind of busy
the fees can go up if it's not really
that busy it goes down
but the idea is that i think the last
bitcoins will be emitted in like 2130
and so once that happens
the hope is that there'll be so many
people using bitcoin
and there'll be so many transactions and
it will have scaled to meet
the demands of the economy that yeah the
miners can exist easily off of
uh those transactions okay um but the
way that it's done is
uh it's code hardcoded into the bitcoin
code that um the
the bitcoin miners which basically they
are uh you know people who own a
computer in the early days it was any
computer
um now you gotta buy these like two
thousand dollar processors
right yeah or something like that so
just a brief thing about mining and what
it is because it's a big part of
right it's super complicated to
understand it's not super complicated
but
um it is i mean somewhat technical so
the example i give is that
um if you imagine
uh these computers every 10 minutes
well on average 10 minutes they're
they're given a new cryptographic puzzle
to solve
and it's i think of it like a needle in
a haystack
so they start
they start they have to they have to
find the needle
in the hey in this cryptographic
haystack it's basically like
um like if you have an email password
and somebody wants to figure it out
if they don't know you well enough to
like social
engineer you or something they can try
what's called brute forcing it which is
basically like well
i'll try this word that didn't work okay
i'll try that word okay
maybe if i tweak it a little bit here
and people can code computers to do this
and brute force your passwords and so it
just takes
a certain amount of time to to do that
and then eventually they'll guess right
and if you don't have any predictions in
case in in place you'll
you'll have access to your stuff and so
basically these
these computers are trying to brute
force this puzzle
and it's like looking for a needle in a
haystack and so
the first computer that finds the needle
broadcasts hey i found it to the network
and then the rest of the network looks
at the needle
and based on the last
needle that was found they can they can
prove that that this needle is is the
legitimate needle it's the next
it's the next block in the blockchain
they've found they've solved the puzzle
and and then that miner gets a reward
for finding that needle and he also gets
he gets a monetary reward and he also
gets the ability
to write all the transactions that have
happened in that last 10 minutes so if
people
like hey i want to send you some bitcoin
and the other guy said i want to send
you bitcoin
those transactions are all put out there
and
um and they um
and then the miner will who finds the
needle will sweep up those transactions
and then earn the fees off those
transactions and earn the fees off those
transactions as well
and then he'll encode them into
that that needle allows it's more like a
key it allows him to
write to the bitcoin blockchain okay and
that that
that um and then once he does that he
gets
uh a block reward which is the the
that's how bitcoin is created
um so it's a bitcoin bitcoin for that
it's to incentivize people to use to
uh participate in the network and and
validate the transactions
it started off at 50 bitcoin and then
every four years it's hard-coded that it
cuts in half who created the first 50
bitcoins
that would be the anonymous founder
nakamoto
yes a group of founders satoshi toshi
nakamoto right
nobody to this day really knows who he
was if it was
a lone person acting or a group of
individuals
where they come from who you know
there's people who have speculated
certain things
people who have found
like a evidence to try and figure out
where he may have lived or whatever
like based on when he did his posts
people think that he probably lived
in the east coast of the united states
stuff like that but
but or he could just been clever in
every time he posted
posted at a certain time it would make
him look like somewhere else or it could
have been
multiple people but yeah what did he
post he post stuff
it started off uh in a mailing list
called the cipher cup the cypherpunks
right which was formed in like
i think the mid-90s a bunch of
nerds in california san francisco
started doing a little meet-up at uh at
one of the guy's headquarters
what was his name eric hughes i think
and eric hughes wrote the uh cypherpunk
manifesto which you can look up
it's just like a paragraph um
and then uh they had a mailing list and
these guys had been trying for they were
basically a bunch of guys that really
can serve with privacy
and the the cyberpunk manifesto
basically says that
privacy is is key to
free society in this modern era
like cryptographic privacy
and along with those kind of ideas also
come a lot of guys who are interested in
sound money and they know about
how the federal reserve works and how it
basically robs savers of their
money you know over the course of
generations
and uh so they worked on this whole idea
of cryptocurrency
and the nearest thing to it was hashcash
which i think was nick zabo's project
um hashcash was a way to protect you
from email spam by
um basically it would make you do a
little computational work he invented
proof of work basically which is what
what the minor the mining algorithm sort
of is for bitcoin um
basically said you have to do a little
computer computational work
to send an email that way if somebody
couldn't just
send out a zillion emails as spam to
somebody
yeah i think that was like 90 uh it was
like 2 000
something 2003 or four he came out with
that
and then satoshi makamoto just basically
came out of the blue
like i just started posting in this
thing and and they dropped the the white
paper for bitcoin
and this thing and everyone's kind of
like well this is really interesting and
what nakamoto had done is he just
basically had taken a lot of the stuff
that the cypherpunks had
learned and figured out and just kind of
put them together nicely into this
nice package and and coded it up and
and launched it and so he was the one
that to answer your question
uh he or she whatever uh was the one
that
mined the first blocks of bitcoin and
the first transaction
mined the first blocks of it's called
the genesis
block it's the first genesis block for
some block of information
it was empty because there were no
transactions right it didn't even exist
right nothing was there
nothing was there but it did reward him
with 50 bitcoins to his
to his bitcoin wallet you know that he
could created so and he actually
uh i think he ran it as kind of a test
net for a while
uh he did send some bitcoin to hal
finney who's now dead
um he was another cypherpunk contributor
that was i think the first bitcoin
transaction where he sent you know he's
like okay
download the software the software
creates what's known as a wallet file
and i'll send you some and it worked but
it's another kind of
breadcrumb is they they think that
nakamoto may have worked in some kind of
lab
where he had access to a bunch of
computers because he actually had a
you could he actually had a whole bunch
of computers that were mining
in the beginning that he was testing
with like it was something like 30 or 40
computers
and they were all kind of the same they
all kind of
did blocks at about the same time
so they it took them about the same time
to find the needle so they figured
they're probably about the same type of
computer
but that's kind of a rabbit hole yeah
but that's that's who mine the first
bitcoins
um
foreign